turning to
politics now at 11 o'clock tomorrow is
the first day of the democratic national
convention
where joe biden will formally accept the
party's nomination for president
but due to the coronavirus it will all
be virtual and some nevadans will take
center stage this year
orco mana joins us live in the newsroom
now with more on what we can expect
orco well sasha the democratic national
convention was supposed to take place
in person in milwaukee but it has
shifted online in the wake of the
coronavirus
still nevada democrats are excited for
this new opportunity
and ready for some local leaders to
share the spotlight
my fellow americans cheering crowds with
densely packed delegates it's what we've
come to expect from the democratic
national convention
but this year because of covet 19 the
applause field arenas are being replaced
by an
online occasion it's a tremendous honor
to get to represent nevada
nevada state senator ivana cancella is
speaking at the convention on tuesday
she's one of 17 democrats nationwide
chosen as keynote speakers described by
the dnc as rising stars of the party
it's really a testament to where the
democratic party sees itself going into
a place that is
diverse is inclusive is progressive as
far as the virtual format for her
address
much more creative than just giving a
formal speech
u.s senator from nevada catherine cortez
masto will speak
monday night everyone showing support
for joe biden and kamala harris but a
trump campaign spokesperson tells me
quote as the dnc convention convenes
this week nevadans will see the far left
socialist policies that make biden and
harris the most extreme ticket in
history
president trump will continue to put
america first this is a time
for us to unite nevada democrats are
planning watch parties all week calling
this the most accessible convention yet
our goal within the party is to make
sure that we have as many nevada
democrats as possible participating
and also it's important for them to
understand what's exactly at stake
in this election and they hope to
inspire involvement all the way to the
ballot box
to engage democrats to watch the
convention but to then take that energy
into election day again the democratic
national convention begins tomorrow and
continues through august 20th
the republican national convention is
set to take place
next week live in the newsroom tonight
orco mana 8 news now